a man of many names and just as many
faces with one characteristic
unsettlingly wide smile Dr Alto cleff
has been one of the SCP foundation's
most valuable researchers granted he
also happens to be their most infamous
and would almost take the title of their
strangest member of Personnel in fact
clef might be tied for the title of
strangest with one other researcher who
was literally turned into a dog but what
does an average day look like for the
so-called ukulele man sure somebody of
cleft's reputation as a violent
unpredictable and enigmatic figure
doesn't just punch the clock at the
foundation and settle for a boring day
filing paperwork well if you've ever
wondered what his normal schedule might
look like then luckily we've prepared a
look at a day in the life of Dr Alto
cleff 6 AM rising at an hour most
Ordinary People would consider absurdly
early Alto cleft seemingly begins his
day much like the rest of us he sits up
in bed gets to his feet and washes
himself thoroughly to prepare for the
day ahead in order to make the most
effective use of this time in the
morning despite being up at the break of
dawn clef likes to complete smaller
trivial tasks in regards to his personal
health hygiene although it does little
to change the unsettling aura that
follows him around never let it be said
that Dr cleff doesn't take meticulous
care of himself perhaps even to a
neurotic degree he'll begin with
exercise usually trying to break his
record for number of pull-ups and
push-ups he can complete in a short
amount of time if he finds his face is a
little puffy first thing in the morning
he'll instead Don an ice pack while
doing stomach crunches his record for
those a thousand in a row and Counting
clef will then follow this up with
showering using this time under the
water to meditate it seems odd for
someone known for his various acts of
great violence but even alto clef can
take a moment for calm reflective
meditation then while showering he moves
on to the application of a deep for
cleansing lotion and is particularly
fond of his honey almond body scrub then
exiting and applying an herb mint face
mask which he leaves on for 10 minutes
as part of his routine Dr clef engages
in his strangest morning activity while
standing in front of the mirror in his
private quarters he will just stare at
himself it's certainly an odd action
especially spending such a specific
allotment of time doing so but even more
unusual is how he seems to practice
smiling whenever photographed Dr Alto
cleft's face is always bizarrely
replaced with that of a random animal or
object each time the animal's face will
be sporting a wide almost abnormal grin
the same expression cleft practices in
the mirror each morning it is still
unknown whether the concealment of his
face to photography is an active or
passive ability Dr clef possesses
whether he does it on purpose or can't
help it 8 AM breakfast is usually a meal
clef skips instead of cereal or even a
healthy piece of fruit every morning
he'll sustain himself on more vitamins
than any normal human being would take
in a week we do not recommend trying
this at home being awake so early
affords Dr clef the luxury of a few
moments down time before the beginning
of a long working day at the SCP
Foundation part of Alto cleft's Infamous
reputation is he is known to be
something of a weapon's Enthusiast and
often acts as a go-to executioner when
the foundation needs an anomaly taken
care of as a result and as it pertains
to his job during clef's morning
downtime he familiarizes himself with
one of his favorite Armament
Publications guns guns and oh look more
guns although how he acquires these
magazines and indeed who actually
publishes them is unknown alternatively
he will request SCP archive files to be
delivered to his quarters so he can read
up on any anomalies the foundation has
encountered that might have the
potential to be weaponized of course
this is more just a hobby not something
cleft would actually attempt unless
asked to but speaking of having things
delivered to his room it is normally
around this time of the morning that a
frightened member of d-class is sent to
knock on Dr clef's door now this too
seems rather odd the role of d-class is
to be Expendable usually as human test
subjects for anomalies placed in
dangerous situations so as not to cost
the lives of foundation Personnel then
of course knocking on the door to Alto
Cliff's quarters is potentially a rather
dangerous situation it's hard to know
for certain if the d-class sent to
hand-delivered Dr clef's daily itinerary
Will Survive the encounter given his
renowned unpredictability it usually
ends up being a 50 50 coin toss of
course it does beg the question why
doesn't the foundation just send clef an
email to notify him what anomaly he'll
be decommissioning but then again being
handed a paper itinerary by a d-class
was something that clef himself
requested 10 AM by late morning Alto has
normally finished cleaning up what was
left of his ill-fated d-class messenger
unless he was in the mood to spare them
sure killing them certainly seemed an
excessive practice to engage in but
cleff had seemingly convinced the
foundation that it was necessary for him
to function it is obvious that this
diabolical doctor is well aware of his
usefulness to the foundation he has long
proven himself to be highly proficient
at dispatching dangerous anomalies with
ease so it's likely the foundation
fulfills his bloodthirsty requests
thanks to that factor after all they
would hardly be likely to offer up a
sacrificial lamb even a member of
d-class to anyone else well say for Dr
Bright's new body quota but Dr clef has
always been capable of producing results
that align with the foundation's
objectives no matter the cost incurred
clef has been known to deem any losses
even the deaths of civilians to be
acceptable collateral damage in order to
kill or contain anomalies and he's under
no illusions that the foundation
wouldn't indulge his erratic Behavior if
not for his track record however not one
in the foundation knew for certain if Dr
cleff even needed to start his day with
such gratuitous violence as well as
being renowned as a killer clef was also
a prolific liar were there legitimate
reasons for him starting his day like
this or was it all just a front merely
done so he could continue to promote his
self-image as the foundation's most
ruthless researcher the lack of a clear
answer was widely considered to be
frustrating to other members of
foundation Personnel 12 p.m noon and
after a few hours of tending to his
duties as the department head for the
division of training and development
clef usually takes a prompt lunch break
every day as the clock strikes exactly
midday on the precise hour of 12 o'clock
Dr Alto klaff will stride into the mess
hall there are a number of foundation
researchers will normally be gathered
eating lunch and quietly conversing
amongst themselves popular lunchtime
topics of conversation usually tend to
revolve around ways the foundation could
try to eliminate
scp-682 or which type of pie is being
served in the commissary on this
particular day it's Apple pecan in case
you were wondering naturally as with
many things that Dr cleff does his
reasons for taking a trip into the mess
hall aren't all the same as any normal
persons that is to say he doesn't go
there to eat or at least in the
conventional sense what Alto cleft does
every lunchtime without fail is
deliberately and methodically Pace his
way around the mess hall in his hands is
his ukulele the instrument from which
his various monikers have been derived
ukulele man agent ukulele even autocleff
is a nickname the doctor has always
claimed his real name is an a major
chord played on a ukulele making it
unpronounceable to humans with his
preferred instrument in hand cleft will
plod between the tables that eating
researchers are sitting at each step he
takes is punctuated by the strum of a
note on his ukulele as he'll play a
random song painfully slowly as he
strides around one lunchtime Simon took
him an entire two hours to get through a
rendition of Smoke on the Water note by
agonizing note even though it doesn't
seem to be a meal in the traditional
sense meaning it offers him no
nutritional value cleft professes that
his midday ritual allows him to feed on
the fear of his fellow researchers
seeing him creepily walk around and
playing slow drawn out Renditions of
songs on his ukulele is occasionally
something that intimidates the newer
Personnel at the foundation but anyone
who has been there for long enough just
finds it annoying which might be clef's
intention that or simply fueling his own
ego 1 30 PM usually by the time an hour
and a half have elapsed from the start
of his lunch break autoclaf will
reluctantly return to his work he'll
often proceed over the course of a
mid-afternoon to conduct Research into
the latest reality warping anomaly he
has been tasked with decommissioning for
that day it was during one such time of
day that he came upon with his plan for
the now Infamous SCP p239 incident an
anomalous girl was recovered by the
foundation with the ability to alter
reality specifically relating to her or
her immediate surroundings Dr clef
viewed scp-239 as a threat to security
and that the foundation repeatedly
overestimated its ability to contain
reality altering entities so cleft
proposed a plan involving a sharp
Implement made out of scp-148 a metal
that could block certain anomalous
properties clef even volunteers himself
to terminate scp-239 personally and
would have succeeded had the foundation
not intervened most of the plans Dr Alto
cleft devise usually placed emphasis on
eliminating anomalies instead of
containing them or making them safe
additionally his schemes almost always
end in a large number of deaths either
of disposable d-class Personnel or of
civilians on this particular day Dr clef
had been tasked with an assignment he
found to be particularly egregious
curing something May namely scp-451 a
former Foundation agent who suffered an
accident with an anomalous artifact that
made him unable to perceive other people
around him the agent quickly came to the
conclusion that he was the last
surviving person on the planet and that
he was responsible for wiping out the
human race naturally cleft's proposed
solution to the problem was to Simply
kill scp-451 he could still be seen by
other Foundation staff but nobody could
interact with him directly it was as
though the artifact had caused a reality
warping event focused solely on that one
agent shifting him just outside of
reality itself however after spending
hours brainstorming away to decommission
scp-451 another researcher reminded Dr
clef that the agent could no longer be
killed as a result in a fit of Madness
clef instead killed that researcher
before continuing as if he had been
unfazed by that information 4pm despite
normally having done barely enough work
to justify it at this point in his day
clef often likes to treat himself to an
additional unearned break as with much
of his regular flouting of rules he
often rationalizes the extra time off
with the knowledge that he is apparently
Untouchable clef knows there is very
little the foundation can do to
reprimand him given both his status has
a high value researcher and his
historical track record for dealing with
anomalies simultaneously he liked to
exercise his immunity to both
consequences and the effects of certain
anomalies part of what makes clef such a
valuable asset to the SCP Foundation is
not just his extensive knowledge of
reality warpers although he is
considered perhaps the leading expert in
such scps but Alto has also been known
to negate the anomalous abilities of
some scps rendering him unaffected in
the same way ordinary researchers are
much like his fellow long-standing
Foundation scientist colleague Dr Jack
Bright this has rendered cleft largely
indestructible and unharmable to a
majority of anomalies allowing him to
continue his tenure at the foundation
for a considerable time as a result of
this natural immunity it is often during
this part of his day that Dr clef likes
to pay visits to a former romantic flame
SCP-173 yes the sculpture the concrete
and rebar anomaly capable of moving at
impossible speeds when unobserved Dr
clef and SCP-173 have what you might
call a um
special bond although the sculpture
seems somewhat indifferent to him given
that it cannot move clef however has
been known to be infatuated with SCP-173
able to view it without being harmed the
unlikely couple have even on a number of
occasions shared romantic evenings in
each other's company in the dining room
of site 19 listening to Barry White and
enjoying an Exquisite meal prepared by a
d-class clef enjoyed the company of
SCP-173 the sculpture wearing a black
dress and a blonde wig every week he
looked forward to Friday their date
night 7 PM okay let's see the damage
today Dr Gear's size by this point in
the day one of the last few orders of
business on Dr clef's itinerary was
always his daily mandatory reprimand
despite there being little punishments
that the foundation could issue Alto
with for both his annoying and alarming
actions they would still regularly
subject cleft to a list of his recent
rule violations and casualties at this
time of 7 PM we've logged over 50
confirmed instances of personnel deaths
on site Dr gears reads aloud rolling his
eyes only 50 I must have had a slow day
cleft responds that is if you're sure
your numbers are right well after this
game of yours doesn't get any less
tiring the other researcher tells him if
you killed anyone else today please just
cut to the Chase and tell me how many
and if you think that it's funny to keep
stashing bodies all over the place then
one it's not and two I need to know
where those are too oh and uh three just
try for ones for the sake of my sanity
to tell the truth oh Charlie you're no
fun Dr clef replies with a chuckle this
is fun to you gears asks this right here
right now of course not you know me
better than that look we both know the
reason that the folks upstairs get you
to sit me down give me a scolding ah
it's all just a front just a way to stop
any of those other little researchers
getting any big Ideas the count Council
can bear the thought of anyone else
trying to do as I do there's only one Dr
clef and we both know there's nothing
anyone in the foundation can do to stop
me having fun my numbers are just too
good speaking of your numbers gears
ignores him says here you've received
420 complaints about the ukulele playing
you want to cut to the Chase and tell me
how many of these were filed by you as
pranks first off nice second off ah
Charlie you do know me 8pm as very often
happens around the time that most
Personnel have punched their cards for
the day Dr clef is approached by a
trembling researcher trying hard to hide
the fear on their face while starting as
a more intermittent occurrence
encounters like this have become so
frequent that they have since come to
form a regular part of cleft's daily
routine I'm on to you clef the
researcher said nervously they were the
latest in a long line to Foundation
staff to confront Dr clef about his
supposed true nature given his violent
and unpredictable Behavior there were
rampant rumors that there was more to
him than it first seemed come on then
kid he says I haven't got all night
let's hear what you think you've got you
were with the global occult Coalition
before you defected to the foundation
the researcher declared summoning up
more courage even if it was a facade you
wrote their handbook on reality Benders
but nobody in the world could have that
much knowledge about anomalies like that
unless they were also one ooh spooky Dr
cleft taunts inching closer with his
ukulele in one hand the foundation
literally let you get away with murder
your face can't be photographed without
changing the image into grinning animals
you
go on you can do it cleft urges you're
an anomaly and SCP you've broken out of
containment and you're warping reality
to avoid detection the researcher blurts
out adding you're the devil oh I'm
disappointed glove Turtles finding this
Theory amusing you almost stuck The
Landing why throw in something so
unoriginal let me ask you do you
honestly think you're the first the only
one in the foundation to uh you know
connect all the dots and figure out the
truth behind alto clef you aren't if I
was an anomaly or the devil aren't I
being a little too obvious about it with
a clunk of a ukulele against the
researcher's head clef gets one more
decommissioning in before bedtime
perhaps there is some truth to what he
says maybe his power isn't just his
immortality or combat prowess or
immunity to anomalies it could be how
he's been able to influence everyone's
perception of him even manipulating the
o5 council into thinking he's too big of
a threat his actions have made them
believe that Dr clef is better kept on
side as an asset than to roam free is a
dangerous enemy to the foundation that
could be what he wants them to think
even if it's not true after all alto
clef is a notorious liar his entire
Persona could be the ultimate lie 10 pm
after another day of murder in Mayhem
mostly of his own doing Dr Alto cleff
returns to his quarters long after the
working day is officially over after
disposing of the evidence of his latest
decommissioning he makes his way back to
the room he started the day in and will
start the next one in two but if you
think that clef just gets into pajamas
hops in bed and has a full eight hours
of sleep like a normal person then you'd
be way way off firstly on his way back
to his room clef will once again have
his ukulele with him strumming
sinisterly away at the string so
everyone knows as they try to sleep in
their own quarters that he's still awake
what's worse is at this time of night
Alto in 10 intentionally mistunes his
instrument making it all the more
egregious to hear keeping the other
researchers up until he finally makes it
back to his own quarters you might think
he would have the sense to stop there
but he doesn't still discordantly and
tomblessly plucking at the strings
usually until someone dares to gather up
The Bravery to complain about the noise
all of it is to add fuel to the fire of
his reputation His Image as an unhinged
unreasonable and untrustworthy Force his
behavior is also carefully curated and
performed with the intention to make the
rest of the foundation believe there is
something off about him and why well
they're so focused on the strange things
they can see and hear Dr clef doing it
provides a smoke screen that covers up
his true goals all the dark and twisted
things he is truly capable of and if
killing anomalies and Personnel is his
cover one can only imagine what might be
worse than that much in the same vein
even him retreating to his court orders
at the end of the day is designed to get
in the heads of the rest of the
foundation maybe because clef really is
the devil or a reality warping a CP or
perhaps he just enjoys messing with
people making them think he's going to
sleep not one of them knows that he's
actually laying in bed eyes fixed open
as wide as possible with his face locked
in that signature grin now go and check
out Dr clef SCP Foundation researcher
and a day in the life of scp-049 for
more deep Dives on Foundation favorites